there's two reasons why men are
feminized we live in a femme-centric
society men are being raised by women
when they're not um at home then they're
in school being taught and raised by
women
um in a world whereby everything is
catered to women whereby the messaging
from the media is don't be toxically
masculine don't it's okay to cry it's
okay to show your feelings they're like
pushing all this like feminine energy
onto men and I don't think that is just
a coincidence I think the reason they're
doing this is because it's the men that
go to war and it's the men that fight so
when tyranny comes it's the men that go
first if you're able to control the men
and you're able to feminize the men then
you're able to control Society to a much
greater extent you know especially with
the last two years and if we lived in a
society whereby like men were more
masculine and they weren't busy with
their rainbow flags and switching
genders and all that I don't think that
like the last two years would have gone
as far as it did